we like brothers that's my little
brother but we've gone through you know
and and fairness in the interest of full
disclosure you had players on the 76ers
especially guys like Aaron McKee Eric's
throwing them they used to call me an AI
y'all like some damn married couple
because we would literally go one time
we went eight months without speaking
each other eight months
because he didn't like some [__] I wrote
what'd you say I I said no no what about
practice he didn't care about that
believe me
it was like he got mad he got he got mad
because I said that you know he Taking
Liberties you know he's AI but he's
milking every single damn Liberty he
can't he needs to get his act together
he didn't appreciate that and he was so
pissed off we went without talking and
it got to a point where a couple of my
colleagues pulled me to the side and say
yo man you the beat writer for the 76ers
you cannot go eight months without
talking to the Superstar the team and I
said watch what
I said I said I said was he was he I
said so what I said he don't speak he's
still giving quotes in press conferences
and other stuff it ain't stopping me
from doing my job I'm not going to be a
prisoner to a guy that chooses not to
talk to me and so it's so be it and then
his late friend that whole practice
practice we talk about practice what
that fed off of was his frustration
because one of his boys got murdered
right just just a week earlier and so
he's saying like who cares about exactly
well that one that boy that got murdered
God arrested Soul his name was Rob and
he's the one that brought me an AI back
oh wow he's a real good dude real good
real good you know obviously he's a
street kid hey I knew him AI took him
the whole bit but he had a beautiful
heart he was beautiful people
um was always protective of AI then
engaging no stupidness no Shenanigans he
was a really good brother had his heart
in the right place and when A.I wasn't
talking he had me and AI me the night
Club at 2 30 in the morning in
Philadelphia or Spring Garden Street and
got us together to stop the nonsense and
to start talking okay so a street dude
that's cool with AI hits you up and goes
I need you to be yeah he called me you
saw me at the game said meet me here
tonight
and was there any part of you that's
like I'm from the streets
ain't nothing to me you want me to be
there at 3 30 2 30 that's where I'm
gonna be and I showed up by myself I was
like yo what's up so he got us together
y'all need to squash all of this and all
of this other stuff and you know I just
let it hey I know I said you know what
the only thing I said to add that night
I said you always get mad and you think
about what I say you don't give me
enough credit for what I don't say
and he was like my man
[Laughter]
I have no recollection of that but but
but I will tell you I will tell you
first of all a certain codes first of
all certain codes number one it ain't
got to be about that but if it was
something about that I'd be damned if
anybody would ever hear something like
that from me I mean I don't know you and
I wouldn't tell on you in none of my
damn business
I would never do anything
there you go
that's what you're supposed to do it but
but I'm just saying it you know you go
out and it's like listen I'm a reporter
stuff like that don't break no laws
don't get into the police blotters
outside of that all I care about is what
you're doing and none of my business was
going on in your personal life that's
that's my that's my cardinal rule I've
always been that way and I will never
change I'm from Hollis Queens I'm from
the streets of New York City bro there's
a certain code that's applicable
everywhere you go and it transcends race
you understand what I'm saying it's a
bro code you understand you don't do it
period you think that there's nothing to
talk about you think that is why you can
talk to players like you'll say some
crazy [__] to a player but he knows you
he knows where you're from he knows he
respect the code so he'll let you say
more than a guy that's part of it though
but that that's not like I don't have
players that can't stand me or players
that hated me for something that I said
or whatever the case may be but when you
when you say what you just said
understand I don't believe I'm saying
nothing crazy okay my shit's fact-based
so the point is is that I'm not some cat
for the social media account that's just
got an opinion I've been covering the
NBA for nearly 30 years coaches players
owners Executives player Personnel
director Scouts advertisers sponsors
Hangar Rollins Honeys wives but you
brothers sisters parents everything I'm
connected all over the place right right
and so my point is that when I come with
an opinion it's really not just an
opinion so if you see me sometimes on TV
and I'm getting into an argument with
somebody half the time I'm looking at
them like you [__] know I know
no I'm not I'm not making it up you know
it's just that you know I can't say
anything and then when you see me get
really really heated is when I feel like
I'm sitting across from somebody that
knows I know
and knows I can't and won't say take
advantage what I really don't and
they're taking advantage of it when they
know the truth they like they have the
information too yeah so you know that
I'm not telling you all I could say you
know why and by the way for any God
that's in the business that I'm in
please understand something about most
journalists we all know
75 more than what we reveal never forget
that we all know more than we reveal so
your opinion spends more for that it's
just that you know you can't you you
listen you can bring people in the White
House that cover the White House they
don't tell you everything they tell you
there's certain stuff that they tell you
and there's certain stuff that they hold
people that cover Hollywood this certain
stuff that they say and there's certain
stuff that they hold you can't say
everything because if you say everything
no one will trust you that's right yeah
no one would trust me that's right you
got to be you gotta prove that you're
someone who can keep secrets but that's
exactly so that's AI so that's the other
thing is like and I think that's where a
lot of these newer like newer media
struggles is they're running for clout
so fast they get one little tidbit of
Juicy information and instead of storing
that and building trust with somebody
right they throw it out there well you
can retweet it 100 but you consider that
media see I consider that bloggers I
consider that people that's just trying
to create click bait and stuff like that
if you you are a member of the media you
absolutely know that comes along with
the job I'm telling you right now I
don't say 80 of the stuff that I know
wow I cannot 80 80 because the the
objective is to build trust
for you to know you can trust me that
you can talk to me there's plenty of
stars who will remain nameless every
Stephen amen let me talk to you man this
is [__] that's happening wow but you
can't say this has anyone ever been
grateful has anyone ever hit you up and
been most ungrateful that even when
you're closer most are great even when
you're critical no because they get what
I left out yeah right you see what I'm
saying they'll hit you up no they're
just not I mean yeah I got you I got you
and it's cool and so what I'm saying
and here's why I don't get mad at a lot
of I don't get mad at a lot of people
over this because I know people in my
family and people in my inner circle
that are friends and stuff like that
pick up the phone and I'll be like this
who the hell you think you talking to
like I don't know I said I can't say x y
z how do you not know this and you know
me my bad my bad well then what the [__]
you asking me for you know you called me
why did you say this because I can't
right I'm not gonna do that I'm not
gonna violate that code that has nothing
to do with something like for example
you can sit up there I'm famous stay off
too
[Music]
I'm not talking about just anybody I got
family members friends people smoke some
weed okay please destroy the streets you
that's what you do had at least most of
us the point is is that I'm talking
about the cats that has cost them money
so if I'm sitting there and I bring up
something like that right
and then you high as [__]
you walk by the score of his table I
could smell yeah yeah you You Wobble it
around coaches making a call the coach
is making a call everybody knows Sam
please
but the point that I'm trying to make I
love my man Sam I'm glad you brought it
up I miss him okay I can't wait to see
him one of these days but let me tell
you something you can see these guys and
they wobbling they can't understand
plays you know it's not many not most
I'm just talking about a handful of
people you'll see something like that
right
I'll write a story
now this is how I handle it maybe they
dribble out I don't even know what the
hell
I'm saying this is how I'll handle it
yeah I'm not gonna die my mouth I'll be
like this this brother shot three for 23
last night he made this mistake this
mistake doesn't I don't know what the
hell he was doing last night but uh
right because that's me letting you know
I know what the [__] he was doing last
night